we've got tour dates to announce uh
Louisville uh Indianapolis
we added a show in Indianapolis
Shreveport
Louisiana Baton Rouge Louisiana uh
Corpus Christi uh Houston uh we added a
show in Houston added a show in Phoenix
added a show in New York City and added
a show in Austin Texas uh those are all
at theovan.com
t-o-u-r make sure to do ticketing
through those links to get accurately
priced ticketing and uh thank you guys
that's all Return of the Rat tour so if
you've already seen it it'll be similar
to that uh still just so you know we've
got lots of new merch up at
theovanstore.com check out the new
hitter hunting collection
also the new gang gang crew necks in
orange and purple and gold fits we got
the new Rat King t-shirt in purple and
black that thing that's the thing baby
if you haven't seen that one check it
out theovinstore.com
today's guest is a rapper uh he's a
composer
um he's a he's a male fiancee if you
want him to be
uh he's a Vibe he's an energy
um
and I went to his show the other night
had a great time uh he's on tour right
now fresh off his new album marvelous uh
he's been in once before and we're happy
to have him back today's guest is young
gravy
[Music]
people and I
can
see
[Applause]
oh man
dude oh
gravy baby
Theo what's up baby I'm good man it
feels good to have a couple days off
right now yeah thank you thanks for
coming in man I uh
and we didn't play on this also we
didn't plan this yeah we lost the camera
right there yeah what are the odds of
this yeah so I walked up with this
purple sweater on and I was like damn
how cute and then he pulls out the
chains too this is very uh it's a
beautiful moment damn we're a couple of
uh a couple uh lavender scavengers
that's something there you go that's
what Riff Raff would call us what's that
for um my shoe also gang baby damn just
right next to the ankle brace you know
the Vibes God bro I love that [ __ ] like
if you if you're going out you're going
to uh DFW dog oh no VFW now if you break
out the house you're going to DSW Shoes
baby oh DSW bro
I thought you meant I was you were
trying to say some [ __ ] about VFW like
I'm going to hang out with the
whenever Bobby Lee comes on stage I
always say like uh or if I go on after
him at the comedy store I'll always be
like I always tell the crowd like I'm
gonna drop you off at a VFW and let
those boys finish things dude always
tell them that because I think they uh
some of those guys fought like Vietnam
yeah I'm guaranteed bro your show so I
went to your show the other night thank
you very much uh thank you for coming
yeah for setting me up
um dude it was CR like
there's so many did you see the guy
there was a guy who brought his mother
in an urn did you see this guy no I did
not yeah there's a guy who brought his
mother in an urn
and he's like gravy was my mom's
favorite she was like the milk you know
the milf with the most or something he
said and I was like there's no way this
dude's mother is in this urn and she was
man was he in the back or was he on
stage I mean I'm sorry in the crowd or
was he he was in the crowd and you just
talked you spoke with him or you just
yelled that [ __ ] out oh no I spoke with
him oh wow yeah so I was like wow you
have people
non-living people coming yeah man you
know yeah we want one over capacity yeah
I know I know I wonder if they if they
charge them a ticket for it
um no bro it was crazy man I love the
fact you uh there's one thing that I
noticed about your whole
the whole thing you have going on to me
it's like you kind of never know what's
gonna happen a little bit it's like a
it's it's like an energy it's a music it
but it's like do you want to be along
for this journey and you had uh Soulja
Boy came out you had Jesse McCartney
crazy yeah man yeah we just with this
show or this tour uh myself and baby no
money the my co-head liner yeah and he
did a he dude he I I I I wasn't uh
familiar with him and that was great man
he's sick the whole thing just the
energy was great but go on so yeah you
got big no money so so we we've been
boys for like six years and we're like
yo
he used to open for me and then he had
some hits and he's really that kind of
reached like we're kind of neck and neck
like same level like we're [ __ ] doing
this together so I was like yeah when
you got to do a big co-headline tour but
we got to make it epic so like we put so
much money like the production and like
planning it out we made like seven
little acts that you probably saw where
it's like both of us and then one of us
and the other one and then both and then
blah blah blah let me fit in Soulja Boy
and Freddie Dredd and and Jesse and yeah
Freddie Dredd I met him he's sick he's
sick yeah dude he seemed like an Amish
guy that had [ __ ] gone off as far as
you could go from here yeah he's like
I'm about to remix the whole damn Bible
dude at all it's crazy because he's like
a quiet like chill little guy but but
his lyrics are crazy he's talking about
murdering people and [ __ ] he loves you
man he was so grateful to be a part of
it uh he's fire man I love the music I
um
yeah but just the whole thing yeah you
like go through these moments it's like
like the lights will get down low and
there's like people kind of slow dancing
and people touching their own tits I saw
people touching their own tits you don't
see a lot of that and there's some facts
yeah it was like and then it gets to
like these like kind of these Crescendo
levels where it's just
it was just fun man I'm glad you could
see it bro we literally play I think
it's 40 songs I think it's 41. wow
throughout that set yeah we don't do the
full thing of every song but yeah I
think we do about 41 it's like two hour
set and uh I love how it came out Laval
came out I found myself just dude I was
just I was just it was good it was cute
girls there man I met a couple girls
yeah baby um I think I came up and
dapped you up during like the Soulja Boy
set yeah you did I had to sneak out with
a little Montclair jacket on and I was
like all hidden yeah kind of hard to
hide I mean literally the tallest guy in
the world comes by in a jacket it was
like the Abominable [ __ ] flow man bro
flow abominable flow man that's hard
that's what it was man um so tell me a
little bit about touring them because is
this the biggest tour you've ever done
yeah I'd say so I'd say like this tour
as a whole is the most tickets that
we've ever like sold on one tour yeah
because you guys had 4 000 in there the
other night yeah that was fire and like
some of the shows my hometown
Minneapolis we did 7 800 which is
ridiculous so we got Seattle coming up
that's about eight thousand uh uh I'd
say the average is like I don't know 3
500 maybe 4 000 but like man that's
incredible yeah like I trip with Dylan
Francis in February and it was it was a
little bit smaller but it was it was
sick it was wild they're all sold out
too but this one just like went off like
we just we both had big years me and
myself and maybe no money and it's sick
to see it man it's sick to see people so
hyped we do meet and greets every day
and there's like all these that's my
favorite part of it is a meet and greets
where there's these fans that like you
know I really mean some to them and
they'll bring like like a dope story
from their life about how I help them or
they'll bring me like a little gift that
like they made and put some time into
and that [ __ ] isn't that amazing isn't
it amazing you think like we had some
guy brought this one time he made he
chiseled this right that's gorgeous yeah
that type of thing I love it someone
made me a a katana a gold a fully gold
encrusted full-size katana sword and
that's for just you could do is that uh
bring up a katana there Zack let's see
it dude I wonder if I can bring up the
one that I have
uh
uh man it's gold it's covered in yeah I
mean the dude gave me that but it's
covered in gold and it says young gravy
all over at the handles and everything
are purple just like our outfits it's
it's it's gorgeous man and imagine being
able to defend yourself with that one
day somebody rolls onto the tour bus
[ __ ] gets out of hand and that is how
you save
I got a whole like I had a whole I don't
know if you ever talked about this
before but I had a whole phase where I
had like multiple different stalkers and
I actually have another katana
and I mean that wasn't the reason I
bought it I was just drunk and wanted a
sword but uh I had back in Minnesota at
my mom's home I had some stalkers that
were you were living at home with your
mother Yep this was during covid and I
had kids that I was like the early covet
era and I had some kids that were
there's multiple different kids that
like I grew up with that knew where I
lived and knew a lot about me but kind
of went crazy went cuckoo one of them
had like schizophrenia one of them had
uh
uh like level three bipolar where
they're seeing things and damn and he
would like they'd like send me little
messages with them like breathing and
whatnot like weird like movie horror
movie type type stuff wow and uh was it
spooky it was pretty spooky man I mean
it was I wasn't that worried I mean I
was worried about myself but I was more
worried about my mom because they knew
that she lived there oh yeah I was gone
you're gone I was gone a lot and I
didn't want to stress her out so I was
like I like kind of I mean she knew I
was putting up the security system but I
kind of just like didn't stress why I
was like let's put up a security system
you know I got a lot of fans yeah these
trip wires out here like damn bro there
was like moments where uh
they would like start threatening me and
like coming
like near my house and like giving me
information there's one time where where
okay so I had this Katana that's what
we're getting back to I bought a katana
when I was drunk and then there was one
time where that was all I had and I was
in my I was downstairs at my house
saying like the basement with those big
big ass windows on both sides of this
basement right and uh you can see all
over like the backyard in the front yard
and this dude was like claiming that he
was at my house this this stalker fella
so I'm sitting there with the katana
dude and I'm just like thinking about it
I'm like dude what am I gonna do like
how am I gonna slice this add her up
dude it was crazy bro
yeah man so in the end man I actually I
pulled some strings I got a fan to bring
me uh a weapon like a firearm uh and I
ended up realizing after that but you
can actually just legally buy a shotgun
in Minnesota so I got that yeah and um
luckily like right as everything was
peaking
this dude that was gonna cut that was
threatening me and coming to my house uh
uh a Homeworld of mine called the cops
and they showed up at his workplace and
they found an unregistered pistol on him
and he's he's locked up
other kids in an asylum
it was a third one that's not even worth
getting into but he's he's also locked
up do you worry so do you know like the
release dates and stuff or are you
worried about that like kind of thing
because do you think they blame it those
guys are sitting in there like listening
to your tracks but also [ __ ] you know
getting jacked to him and stuff and like
you know like the release dates of their
schizophrenia what you mean no like
release dates have like when do they get
out of these asylums like are they in
there like are they [ __ ] Revenge
lifting you know because there'll be
dudes in there yeah like slow like some
you seen Cape Fear
um yeah yeah I've seen it I've been
there been to Cave here yeah like Cape
Fear like some fully tatted back [ __ ] I
don't know I I
hoping that it's all good there's
certain cities now that I go to where I
always bring security uh but you know I
just have a fear about it because you
know there's always I watched too many
scary movies but I have a fear of like
someone getting a hold of me and like
getting me like tied up in a chair and
doing weird [ __ ] to me man it's my worst
fear damn other than whales I don't like
whales you don't scare me
it's just a big ass animal and like if
you're in the water and it's yeah what
is it about him you think oh I guess if
you're in the water in the well showed
up you have zero chance it's like you're
floating around in the water let's say
you're in the middle of middle of
nowhere there's water that's the ocean
yeah yeah that's exactly what what I was
not bad my bad no no but but thank you
for clarifying and you're in the ocean
in the middle of nowhere and
you know you're just floating trying not
to stay stay afloat and then yeah some
goddamn big ass whale pulls up you see
that first dude first you see that in
the distance you're like bro I'm I'm
stressing right now I think about it bro
that's crazy and what do you even do
then there's not much you can do I think
if you you're is it something you
urinate around you it won't come by you
what is that
shark
maybe I remember this guy with sharks I
don't know about whales I'm really
scared of sharks too man all that [ __ ]
maybe jellyfish if you pee on a
jellyfish or something to leave you
alone no if you if you get stung by
jellyfish and you're supposed to pee on
the on the sting oh damn but dude I
would pee I mean the only thing you
could do is probably pee I think would
probably keep it away from you I don't
know I don't know do whales go away from
urine can you run that yeah I'm Googling
it I think I would just accept my fate
man I think I would just lay there close
my eyes and be like
sorry I can swim away from that
[ __ ] but but but whales don't
need people it would be an accident if
it ate me you see that we all swallow
those two girls yeah we're on the canoe
yeah oh that was crazy dude bro can you
even imagine and it it sent those
[ __ ] back talk yeah they survived
they survived but imagine being a
whale's mouth and then coming out and
then living the rest of your life but
imagine getting rejected by a whale
obviously these these chicks don't have
guys and we're out there together you
know what I'm saying like I'm actually
rejected by a whale hey I don't think
whales can even like digest a human man
I think I'm just afraid of them like
whipping me with their tail or some [ __ ]
oh you know what I'm saying and you're
taller too I think that's one of the
disadvantages of being tall is there's
this there's more of you to get hit
there's more you to get caught in a wood
chipper there's more of you to get uh
wood in a wood or just like anything
anything that's loose if there's
something you know a machine there's a
lot you have a there's a more of a
landscape yeah you know it's like
I don't know I have to worry about
probably a foot less than you see one
thing that I've been told by friends and
and I kind of think is as a fact is that
I'm I'm I'm sick between six seven and
six eight but like my brain I think only
really is aware of like six five so I
have like an extra like two inches of my
body that just kind of I'm a little I'm
not clumsy but like
I'm good about hitting my head on [ __ ]
hitting my arms on [ __ ] breaking bones
like yeah I think I'm just like a little
bit my brain hasn't caught up to the
height
all of it ever will
wow that's fascinating man I I just I
didn't know that something like that
could happen to people because they say
also if you lose an arm somewhere and
you like punch somebody you can still
almost feel like you're punching
somebody the phantom pain [ __ ] is so
interesting to me one of our old uh tour
bus drivers just got his leg amputated
and it like like I was just really
curious it means my boy I said dude
Keith shout out to Keith was he a smoker
no he he got a like a like an infection
in his ankle or something and just
didn't treat it and like I guess enough
time went by where he had to amputate
his leg up to like here upper thigh he
sent me a picture he was crazy uh that's
my boy so I like wanted to learn more
about it and like I like it's really
interesting how that fandom pain works
you know yeah Phantom limb activity yeah
just amazing your limb was like yeah you
think I'm gone [ __ ]
your brand I can't imagine what my brain
what it would feel like man I don't know
yeah it's crazy that are so it just it
it starts to make you wonder what
different interesting things are there
about our brain because bring up Phantom
Pain Zach
um phantom pain is pain that feels like
it's coming from a body part that's no
longer there doctors once believed this
post amputation phenomenon was a
psychological problem but experts now
recognize these real Sensations
originate in the spinal cord so it's
like you don't even have the arm but
like your your cells are telling you
that there's some [ __ ] there and it
hurts yeah it just makes you wonder like
what our brain can really do like are we
mad because that's kind of that's some
wild [ __ ]
there's a lot of wild [ __ ] man I swear
to God I was doing DMT earlier today and
I was like today today yeah yeah well
with a pen you can just hit it and it's
kind of casual you know and I was just
thinking about I was like man like I'm
looking at all my boys I was kind of
hung over I wasn't like feeling perfect
and then I was like
like damn man like this is this good for
me right now or is it bad for me my
brain was just like focusing on so many
things at once and it's like you know
they say you only use like 20 of your
brain or something yeah and I feel like
there's been moments when I was on an
acid where I was I don't know maybe it's
just me being all excited or whatever
but I was like oh I'm using that other
I'm using at least another five percent
right yeah yeah oh that's yeah when you
find that extra gear oh yeah dude yeah
I'm like oh [ __ ] oh God I Won't Suck way
too much of my uh antidepressant on
accident I had like hadn't taken in two
weeks and I thought I was taking like
just like a half of a dose but like I
grabbed the wrong one and it was like
three times the normal dose but I hadn't
taken it in weeks and I like went like
this weird Super Saiyan mode where I was
like thinking fast as [ __ ] and I felt
like a genius bro I was like but but it
actually was good ideas I actually
planned out a whole set for a tour all
this stuff and I my heart was racing so
like I don't think I'm gonna do it again
but I still was kind of in like super
saiyan mode like yo
was it almost like an Adderall or what
was it like I mean like a super Adderall
I take Adderall every day it was it was
like a super crazy Adderall like my
brain it was it was like I had two
brains wow crazy it's a little
Lamotrigine if you guys technical
motogen
um
the motogen low motogen it's probably
not healthy to do to do it but uh if you
ever really need some inspiration maybe
tried weaning off and then busting a
couple little moats wow I take
um
uh I take um
um
Lex bro yeah Lex bro I'm a [ __ ]
Lexapro I'll take Lamotrigine and uh
trintellix those are like my two it's
pretty similar but yeah oh you Alexa
rookie I wonder if that'd be a good
[ __ ] bar Pro you relax a rook maybe
not
um I'm getting cookie
um yeah yeah yeah what's up with your
book
what uh all right so taking on this DMT
like you just hit the pin so the pin
that thing will reorganize you though I
had a man take me one time a man and a
woman
I met them at this smoothie shop right
it was uh this dude who's like a shaman
or like part-time shaman and his wife
and they took him back to their house
they had a DMT like pin they were making
them in uh Maui next you know I'm
sitting there they had children and
everything they had a little bowl of uh
cashews or something I remember and next
thing you know bro I went into the damn
I was out there baby I [ __ ] just just
slipped off you did a little you did the
Blast Off you did the blast yeah because
yeah if you hit it enough it's crazy if
you get over that Hill it's like you go
over to a hill in the back of your head
and it's like it's like going on a rock
bottom from SpongeBob yeah but it's lit
though yeah yeah is that what you did
today no no I was I wasn't going out all
right see I I haven't been able to reach
that without like actually smoking the
physical [ __ ] and it's a lot harder to
get in the pens yeah today it was just
chill I was trying to introduce some of
my friends to it I was peer pressuring
people into doing it yeah I had to do it
first too it's fun first it's fun to see
someone do it the first time because
they don't believe it's gonna happen
that was the thing I couldn't believe it
happened it was like a moving truck
showed up full of like Stardust and
[ __ ] it was like a lgbtq [ __ ]
Royal Rumble and like a bunch of like
African drums and everything and they
all showed up and [ __ ] helped move
all the furniture out of the back of my
soul can you elaborate a little bit on
you said LGBT Q royal rumble meaning oh
dude it was like the whole rainbow was
in that [ __ ] you know I mean every day
had colors that had never even taken
their coat off yeah okay I mean that was
like every I mean it was just Just Roy G
Biv you know he was out I mean it was
colorful as hell I thought you meant
there was like like [ __ ] dicks flying
and oh I'm not I'm sure some stuff was
going on in the back that I can't
guaranteed guaranteed it was behind yeah
yeah okay fair enough every now and then
yeah you'd hear something dude you'd
hear something squeal you know yeah and
you couldn't tell the gender of it [ __ ]
was getting weird you gotta be in a good
mindset because I remember one of the
first times I ever did it it was in
Montana I was living at his commune and
I was uh
it was my first time ever trying it and
I was in his basement and the the
landlord was the one who's put me on the
DMT it was only I was getting tested all
the time because of my my probation and
it was the only drug that doesn't show
up
and he was making it in the kitchen
every day so I said [ __ ] it and uh he
put on this like I was like oh let's
find some chill music like I want to
like hear like some Mac DeMarco or
something he puts on this like tribal
like drums and like
squealing and [ __ ] yeah I was just like
man I was in a weird place bro I was
like I had a great first trip but it was
like
um like tripping like in my whole space
in my head like seeing all this [ __ ] and
then I'll wake up a little bit and I
hear like
like some crazy that's not kind of
racist didn't it just kind of like a you
know what I'm saying just like like
weird-ass noises you know yeah it wasn't
even singing it was like like strings
playing that that type of Melody and
banging drums and all this [ __ ] and I
was like man it was just not
another one tis the season for clean
balls and body
time to get your hair on your body
tightened just dang trim it down baby
God refine your wiener refine your
nipples get the hair off your body if
you want
manscaped can help
they help you clear your driveway for
safe travels this holiday season you
know what I'm talking about body hair
manscapes products are at the top of
every wish list
they offer a handful of different
products
liquid formulations shampoos body washes
body deodorants gels exfoliants they do
it all don't let your chestnuts roast in
the wrong boxers
get yourself a pair of manscaped boxers
specifically made to keep your area cool
crotch area
that's right Dad has nasty nose hairs
trim the mitches you get them save his
life with the weed whacker nose and ear
hair trimmer I use that thing you know
he could Splunk in my snout maybe so I
use that thing
save 20 off in free shipping by going to
manscaped.com
t-h-e-o that's right twenty percent off
and free shipping by going to
manscape.com Theo manscaped for a
perfect gift that will be the holiday's
biggest hit
this episode is brought to you by
betterhelp
if there's something in your life that's
making you uncomfortable making you
unable to manage making you unable to
have peace
well better help can figure that out for
you and with you that's right better
help therapists are trained to help you
figure out the cause of challenging
emotions and learn productive coping
skills better help has connected over
three million people with licensed
therapists it's convenient and
accessible anywhere a hundred percent
online I've used better help and I've
found it to be effective I found it to
be exactly what it says it is
um it's on call it's it's quick
um you can change therapists if you want
if you don't like the therapist you're
using or the one that you've partnered
up with you can try a different one and
I encourage you to do that
um there have been times in my life
where I've spent too much time with one
therapist and I kind of wish I had been
brave enough to just make a change
sometimes I don't want to hurt people's
feelings or whatever that doesn't matter
this is about you getting better
as the world's largest therapy service
better help has matched three million
people with professionally licensed and
vetted therapists available 100 online
plus it's affordable just fill out a
brief questionnaire to match with a
therapist if things aren't clicking you
can easily switch to a new therapist it
couldn't be simpler no waiting rooms no
traffic no endless searching for the
right therapist learn more and save 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash Theo and so there was
that nerve-wracking and then did you
feel if you're you're say you're living
with that man
I was living with that man I was living
with 14 people in a three bedroom home
and you guys were probably smoking weed
huh I couldn't do that [ __ ] oh cause
you're on probation yep so so what are
you doing trying to save money or was it
like a religious thing well I was there
because oh this is perfect Bros I heard
you were in a cult
how was it yeah all right we'll get to
that in a sec so so what happened with
me was I was uh
uh arrested in Georgia for some dumb
[ __ ] I was wrong place wrong time yeah
friend's house but I got I literally got
charged with two charges of breaking and
entering two charges of criminal
trespassing and then like two felonies
for like Xanax and wax because it's in
Georgia that's what it is so I got all
these goddamn charges for this [ __ ]
that like we were just the wrong place
wrong time and I got basically they
realized that they had [ __ ] up uh the
local police did so then the judge gave
me a plea deal where like everything
would get dropped except for one
misdemeanor did you get to pick which
one or the judge kept it he kept it it
was it was criminal trespassing okay and
I got another one like two years later
in Georgia for breaking a new tire store
that's a whole different so don't go to
George's kind of the place George is
where I where I where I [ __ ] up yeah
anyways I um
I had a good friend from high school who
managed a thrift shop in uh Bozeman
Montana and I was like I need to get
away from all my friends back home
Minnesota they're gonna be like they're
gonna convince me to do drugs or
something so I I just drove out brought
my boy Preston I was like bro you just
come with me and he ended up moving
there after that because it is a
beautiful place yeah but yeah I moved
into this house and he gave us a room
with like three mattresses and then I
realized that we had like people there's
people that would sleep in the back in a
yurt there were people that would sleep
in the front in a truck and then we
would have like every room had two
people in it so it was it was like a
little comedy and we'd have like
Community dinners and everything and do
DMT it was it was beautiful I had a
great time yeah but it sounds great it
was straight up 20 24 days straight I
woke up every day and did 10 hours of
community service
and then went home
and [ __ ] was everybody there doing
community service is it kind of a
halfway house for people doing community
services no no not at all okay it was
literally just a bunch of goons and I I
was the one kid that had to do community
service so they were all going on Hikes
and going on trips and doing all their
cool [ __ ] and I was like every day but
but here's the thing was that
part of my plea deal was if you break
any law within the next 18 months until
you're off probation you go to jail for
the rest of 18 months so like if I got a
speeding ticket so that's why I was not
on any I wasn't drinking I wasn't any of
that [ __ ] I just played it safe played
it safe just 10 10 hours a day I'm gonna
did DMT but other besides that 10 hours
a day community service and what was the
community service you were doing I was
working at thrift shop oh really that's
kind of cool shop it wasn't bad there's
really nice ladies like old religions
every shop in Bozeman I feel like yeah
yeah yeah I did that and then I also did
this was interesting so the uh
he's on like the board of the like one
of the chairs of like the whole city I
don't obviously Billy he was oh a
councilman something like that but he
also owned the local sex shop and it was
like this interesting little combo where
I was like kind of helping out that's a
councilman I was helping out at the sex
shop but I was also doing like this
whole social media promo for this like
suicide prevention walk and I was dude
it was I was just taking every single
hour I could get because I did not want
to go to jail at all that was like right
when I started popping off with music
and I was like dog I cannot man so do
you think it was the fact that you were
popping off with music that was keeping
you out of staying out of trouble too
because you were like you had finally
something pretty big on the way on the
other side of the scale no I think
either way I would have man like the
thought of going to jail for 18 months
was was you didn't want it I would never
yeah now looking back with being uh a
rapper being an entertained you wish you
had that jail time not at all I don't
think anyone would yeah yeah I mean just
you mean like just for like for
credibility yeah just for like just
clout just have a little bit of [ __ ]
uh cell clout you know no no no no I got
the charges man and I beat him I think
that's that's that's so close right
there that's a win that's a win
um
so I noticed also it's your show so
do you think of yourself uh what do you
yeah what do you kind of what what do
you kind of what is your genre like your
kind of space in music I I find it to be
really kind of interesting right because
it's also about kind of an energy and
Ambiance you know there's this romantic
kind of side to it all
um
and it's not like traditional music it's
not like really instruments really so
like where do you kind of like
is it do you does that feel challenging
to kind of keep it's almost like a
like what kind of genre would you put it
in I mean you could say rap of course
but like is there it almost has more of
like a
I almost feel like I'm at a not a
carnival but something
I mean the show is is definitely like a
you know cinematic we try to do a lot of
like theatrics with the show and make it
crazy my music style itself uh
I mean I've tried a lot of different
beats but I think like the majority of
them are like sampled trap beats someone
once described it as new Memphis I
thought that was badass basically like
through the Three Six Mafia
you know yeah I loved them growing up so
uh yeah man I mean my music is just it's
just samples that I love and banging
808s and then I spit just what comes to
mind which is you know it's fine yeah
it's here's what I'm realizing finally
it's more about you it's like I go
because I want to be a part of your
world that's what I kind of realize I
think it's not like yes yes the music is
great and and you get attracted to the
Beats everything but I kind of want to
see what is gravey putting together for
me like you it really is like you're
mixing something up you know I really
feel like you're in the like literally
in the kitchen you know that's how I
feel when I'm I like that with with your
whole world you know
um so what do you see like that moving
forward from music like do you see like
because yeah you're kind of like you I
know you did US you guys you did like a
collab or like a sample with little
Wayne I remember
um and you like at the show you have
Draco out there you have [ __ ] Jesse
McCartney which was so ridiculous dude
everybody's like you're just going to
all these different little levels you're
just having such a good time what do you
kind of see like is that kind of tough
to keep up do you feel like that you're
finding your groove even better with
being kind of um uh surprising people
like that like does any of this make any
sense kind of I love it I love it I mean
I think one of my like best qualities
but also like sort of you know stressful
qualities of mine is like I love making
friends and like keeping in touch with
people so like everybody I meet like if
I like if I [ __ ] with them I'm gonna
keep in touch we're gonna keep working
on stuff like Jesse McCartney met like
two or three years ago and I was like
bro like pop out same with soldier boy
um
so I think just like keeping in touch is
sort of the Midwest in me and like
wanting to like you know give these
people a shine if they haven't had one
in a little while or whatever it is uh
but I want to keep on you know working
with artists that are kind of outside of
my my Lane because I collab maybe the
money a lot I collab with a couple of
the rappers in my space but like usually
if I get a feature it's just an artist
that I really like that I want to have
on my album my fans are like these
called fans that like they don't really
care
who the feature is they just want to
listen to my music so like I mean in the
past I've had young Dolph rip I've had
man I mean Juicy J I've had a lot of
artists that I love that will kill it on
the track and then people will become
hip to them
uh just because I love those artists so
so I've been thinking about like in the
future who I want to collab with uh it's
almost like a podcast it's almost like
you bring people on for an episode that
you like spending time with
as you're saying that it makes me feel
like that you know a little bit
um and you are like that man I'll say
that anytime you come in town that
you're shooting something you've always
invited me out to be a part of the shoot
man yeah bro it's something I see you
bro of course
um and um yeah you always kind of fill
me in what's going on you know you do do
a good job of that it's hard it's a lot
of pressure too probably there's a lot
of texts yeah I do get a lot yeah that
that's that's the issue with with the
keeping in touch everybody's my texture
was blown up and I'm like I'm you know I
don't want to curb anybody so so I keep
in touch but uh I'm curious man like
like should I I got something coming
with Michael Buble oh wow yeah I was
just thinking who would be really good I
wanted to hear your thoughts after you
saw the show like who should I you think
I should work with
man it's so funny because there's a lot
of different little there's a lot of
different
kind of where I'm trying to think of
like a unique country artists that would
be kind of cool you know well I'm pretty
close with Morgan Wallen and Hardy oh
Morgan loves you that's right you were
supposed to do uh weren't you gonna be
at their they had a party a couple weeks
ago there was an LA show they were doing
that I was gonna like pop out at yeah
but I couldn't make it because I was on
tour oh because I talked to his
management they were asking if I want to
come be a part of I think it was like a
big loud party oh it was Morgan's like
man some man of the year
they were like gravy's gonna come Morgan
loves Craig and I was like oh that's so
crazy what a small world it's funny me
Morgan and Hardy were just like one of
us is drunk we'll just like FaceTime
each other and like just talk it's so
good cute [ __ ] man it's cute bro yeah
he's got a date this they just put up a
new towards him Hardy and Parker
McCollum which is wow that's
unbelievable that's so crazy Hardy's
like such like a kid rock yeah it's so
interesting I'm trying to see because I
could almost see you going like I could
see you doing something with like a
George Strait almost like I love
bringing in artists that are like
unexpected you know that's what I'm like
I mean I could see you doing anything
with like somebody kind of young I'm
trying to think of something that would
be really like
um I thought about like I mean I
actually just got connected with with 50
Cent because of Lisa Ann Lisa Ann and I
have become close of 50 cents a future
one and I like the idea of bringing back
like rappers that like I love growing up
to put him on a song now yeah T-Pain I
just got on the track recently
that's so uh yeah that's so great man
yeah I'm trying to think of what would
be cool I mean obviously doing something
like with Morgan Hardy those guys with
big loud with that group would be really
sweet for sure what about a do like
about like a cool ballad with a bad
[ __ ] you know what I'm talking about
singing some cute activity man so I'm
just yeah dude I'm trying to think of
who
um what about there's a young girl named
Jesse Murphy you know that is
um I had I had someone that works with
Dojo cat but like we didn't really
work out in the end yeah oh that slide
dude I could see something almost
bizarre with like a
Sinead O'Connor she's like an old she's
like a that song nothing compares to you
from that song
no she was like oh I need like a like
like a Whitney Houston type R.I.P but
she was like a white knee Houston
Whitney Houston yeah that's who she was
man word all right bring up a picture of
her if you can brother help me out here
that's her right there Sinead O'Connor
man
yeah oh and she smokes too I think she
might have smoked her throat out who's
the girl with the Love is a Battlefield
uh
movies oh is that Fleetwood Max No No
Love is a Battlefield oh that's awesome
Pat Benatar Pat Benatar let me see her
real quick
she's banging
yeah bring up that Patty B she's alive
I'm gonna hit her up right now ah she
gotta be oh yeah yeah that's a play
right there
well there's a battlefield I want to
sample that at least or should I maybe
something dope with Shania would be
though it would be crazy he's fired yeah
yeah god dude all right I think I think
I think we found the lane man I need to
get with some of these epic female
artists of the of the past decades and
make something crazy happen well it's
kind of what's really neat about you is
that you have this you're you're like
this energy so it's almost like you can
attach the energy almost to anywhere you
know
um
thank you yeah it's cool man it's dude
it's exciting when I came the other
night I was like wow I was standing
there with Trevor because I went with
Trevor Wallace and we're standing there
in the back and we were both just like
man this is so cool hey just cool that
he goes this is really cool to see one
of my friends have success you know and
I was just like man this is just so much
I was just having so much fun
um and that was nice it's like to go to
a place and you [ __ ] you know you're
kind of fill them with you know you're
excited when you get there but then
you're like damn this is awesome you got
to see the whole show you just the whole
thing no I saw probably I would say 75
you leave by the end yeah
then's the latest it is oh dude it was
getting lit as we're walking out we
could hear how lit it was getting fair
enough oh but I had to work the next
morning you know I get it
um
what uh oh and then I also saw everybody
so people's throwing those damn tit
mittens the whole time people are
humming those [ __ ] uh yeah the
boulder holder oh baby people are
throwing those damn [ __ ] those damn
[ __ ] those people had some damn
[ __ ] uh big old tick tickies man I'm
telling you oh there was breasts oh the
bras and the they kept getting caught on
the security guards they were in front
of the stage that was the best part it's
funny because yeah yeah so so that that
started on one of the first shows I mean
I always have shows where people throw
bras but those be a few and here it is
right here so we'll throw in some of
them
people titting out yes dude and are they
warm when they hit up there and some are
they just uh usually I'll usually I mean
like sometimes I'll catch them which is
badass if like someone throws it and I
catch it in there and it looks cool but
uh
but yeah man they uh people yeah I mean
I mean ever since so I posted this video
about it and then ever since then now
every show I'm getting like a ton like I
basically promised
I did promise and yeah you guys are
doing a chair it's uh so I'm donating
all the bras but but I'm gonna take the
the value of all them which kind of was
decided amongst the people on like the
comments that it's like about 50 bucks a
pop for one of them nice bras oh wow so
like based on the amount of the number
we get I'm guessing it'll be like a
little I mean probably a little bit over
a thousand because we were at like 800
right now now I'll probably be a little
more than that anyways I'm gonna donate
50 bucks a pop so it's gonna be like
quick 60 bands to the breast cancer man
God I know it's magical yeah gotta do it
oh we have to keep breasts out there
imagine if suddenly they said nah no
more bro no more breasts yeah man that'd
be problematic as hell you remember some
of the greatest breasts you've ever seen
is there a pair
it's breasts are only it's hard to keep
a long breasts don't hold a long time in
your head I feel like it has to be
recent breaths yeah that's a good
question man wow Lisa Ann has pretty
cool tits
um yeah no you guys got together and
she's a famous uh pornographic actress
right I I'm sure I saw her I don't know
I mean I always used to watch a lot of
it oh you would did you see what she
looks like let me bring her up please
Zachary you will recognize her bro
guaranteed it guarantee it oh wow get it
get up get a good one she did the Sarah
Palin one that's what she blew up oh
yeah
yeah
so I'm going to the AVN Awards with me
and she's a
porn legend she's kind of we're doing
retired for a few years but she's she
has some cool tits
and is she um and you guys uh went on a
date you guys have gone on some dates
right I wrote a song where I had a lyric
about her and yeah yep and she loved it
and um then I ended up getting her into
this uh
I had to shoot a commercial for Jeep he
was like oh we need a mouth I was like
well if you're in New York let me hit up
Lisa she was super about it we met and
you know we had a bonded pretty well on
set and
um
yeah the rest is history I clapped her
cheeks damn boy wow two minutes it was a
dream of mine because I think
one of my first three ever jerk offs in
my life was to her oh wow I want to say
yeah first ever three three nuts and I I
uh I know I have you know and do you
remember the first time he ever
ejaculated was it surprising to you yeah
it was mind-blowing I lost my [ __ ] I had
like a family computer room where like
it was like this room off to the side
right next to my parents room so I had
to like you know I think the first porn
ever watched it was like the girl from
Buffy the Vampire Slayer and she was
just like
stripping in the rain I don't even know
if there was even breasts involved so it
was an actual pornography it was just
like video of someone but it was like
getting close to it you know I think I
think I Googled like cool boobs I think
that was my first or hot boobs that was
my first ever
porn search and then I found it I was
like because I heard people at lunch
talking about jerking off and I was like
and you didn't and now did you you know
what it was yeah I do I had no idea this
is like uh man sixth grade the good
thing about when you hear that jerking
off you almost you can kind of figure
out even if you're like you know even if
you can't even read or anything you can
kind of figure out what you have to do
to kind of achieve it it's yeah you know
you can only test everything so much
before you [ __ ] yeah so I tested that
[ __ ] out man I was I remember I think I
think everyone's first note might be
their best best nut oh it's just insane
well I just feel like the I remember the
ejaculate
or the e-jack or whatever they call it
you know
um yeah it's so at that point it's so
clear yeah I remember being like it had
just
I mean like it had just come out of like
it was just pure man it was like plasma
it's like a pure oh child
nut you know what I'm saying no
yeah man that was uh let's all say it
again I know what you're saying because
I was a child and you were a child so we
can say it but I think yeah it's weird I
don't want to think about it but I think
about it but yeah we were talking about
ourselves as yeah yeah it was our own
pure child's nuts so yeah dude if I'm
thinking about my own self and
Jacqueline as a kid that's not like
pedophile stuff is it no no it's your
own nut man I'll never forget my first
like five nights how old were you when
you first boss said well yeah thanks man
how old were you
um I was uh oh I think I remember I was
like 13. and I didn't really know I
remember like
uh finding some videos right my brother
had some pornography up there hidden in
his closet and some Alize whiskey pull
up some Alize Ali hey bro I'll still sip
smells everywhere oh dude yeah if I want
my camera so you got into the whiskey
it's not like a weird little like it's a
mix it's like a little bit oh there it
is right now upstairs right there get
that orange one baby or the oh yeah that
one that's what I remember yeah oh god
dude oh that was that shit's popping
especially like
oh I can Belch and taste my childhood
even just looking at it and so he had a
he had a jug of that up there and I
found some videos on his shelf and so I
hit two swigs of that
and I fell off the shelf man I got drunk
it was like I climbed up some shells in
his closet and fell off that [ __ ] and
then jerked off and then I I kind of
came too I think I even blacked out and
damn that's a crazy first night there
was a lot going on and then I got these
videos and I put in the video player and
I just remember like laying in his in my
brother's bed because his bed was by the
TV and he was out of town and like I
like your brother's bed was your first
first night I didn't think about that
crazy damn bro all right you know things
happen
God bro but he wasn't there yeah no I
respect it this is how it's cleaned up a
little bit
oh yeah dude I think yeah I mean I think
it just evaporated back into my skin it
was like you know that [ __ ] was pure
that was damn place let's try to reform
a thumb you know really bro if you were
missing something you could fill them in
a divot on your body but I do remember
like having my legs out and I remember
just kind of rubbing my I was so like
irre like just volatile from watching
the pornography that I remember even
just rubbing my legs together like this
and that alone was just too much going
oh it was just too much Charisma going
on just heat yeah oh I even just my own
legs because I'd never like if you took
30 seconds before if I'd rub my legs
that had been nothing but now that I'm
all keened in on this pornography and
titty on the video
um it just had taken a new level and I
just
do that oh I had no prior knowledge of
what was about to go down so I'm in that
[ __ ] like just you know getting to it
however I could I think I might have had
like a silky napkin or something oh God
yeah of course you would
you're gonna stop I mean I'm surprised
you have a cable on Brandon no no no no
bro I was like third I was not balling
when I was [ __ ] 14 man I uh
yeah I don't know some napkin and and I
just remember like it was like damn this
is cool man I'm really getting into this
and then I busted and I was like you
know it's like a it's like take it's
like blasting off on DMT I was like it
really is damn I was like that's what
happens and then my dick look [ __ ] up
for like two days oh wow really Jesus it
just had been so swollen you know what
I'm saying yeah
yeah it is it's almost like popping a
pimple for the first time yeah God I
remember I remember I saw a man
um cream out on a video
and I was like there's no way it must be
a special effect or something yeah and
so I remember you know doing myself like
that just genie in my little lamp dude
and God damn brother I mean just
somebody somebody wished for damn semen
I would I would pay money to have my
first jerk off again man I swear to God
goodness gracious
and pay money for what and like just
just have it just to have never nutted
in my life oh to scratch all the nuts I
ever took and just have my first again
right now
dude I think you have to uh there's
that's like born again Christian or not
I don't know if that they do it there
but secondly baptized and have a good
another first jerk off but you can't
really do all the reverse God yeah I
think it's over man the track has been
worn in these I've damaged the goods
God but there is something about it man
if you go all the way back it almost
feels like you'd never die if you had
never jerked off
wow
it was deep
I think I agree with that
you don't have to agree with that
statement man [ __ ] it's like you'd have
this power inside of you God
smash your shoes bro you're rocking
olive green with the I'll try to match
my [ __ ] up yeah you did a better job I
um I had to do that uh BFFs pod this
morning so yeah they brought you what
did we tell oh I told them they said
who's coming on I said gravy's coming on
and what were they they were talking
about something about a woman that you
had dated but I didn't know who it was I
guess it was someone's mom yeah
someone's mom
so uh of course they did yeah they
brought that up but it was pretty
interesting I think
um it was just early I had to be over
there like 9 00 a.m and I was like I
don't even want to be up at this moment
I just I stayed up kind of late so you
did it yeah but hey but did what I was
supposed to do and that was a good time
um
yeah I'm trying to think I feel like I
didn't help you out on that collab very
much sounds like a piss yeah we do that
yeah go piss oh definitely we do it all
the time you know the most wonderful
time of year is also the most hectic
time of year
everyone puts off shopping until the
last minute
and if you have an online store that you
run or you're in charge of you know the
feeling of getting hit with a ton of
orders at once
well ship station turns holiday ship
storms into smooth sailing
so you can keep your customers happy and
still find time to enjoy some eggnog
ship station works with all your
favorite places to sell online including
Shopify Etsy Amazon eBay and more
manage every order from one simple
dashboard automate routine shipping
tasks print shipping labels and easily
compare rates and delivery times to
optimize every shipment
this holiday season give yourself the
gifts the gift
of stress free holiday shipping use
promo code Theo today at shipstation.com
to sign up for your free 60-day trial
that's
shipstation.com promo code t-h-e-o
I just ordered a new batch of these I
use them I need them I gotta weiner up
and Weiner and do and get good wiener
and it helps
Bluetooth is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis but in
chewable form and at a fraction of the
cost
that's right Bluetooth if you're looking
for that extra confidence when it's time
for sex
bluetooth.com is where you find it
they also now have Varden Apple mint
flavored chew apples baby with the
active ingredient in levitrin staxon so
you can stay hard and fresh God
he's hard
if you don't like swallowing pills no
problem
Bluetooth sildenafil and title Apple
check tablets are chewable
chew them up
that's it Bluetooth tablets are made in
the USA Baby
get that Hacksaw Jim Duggan you feel me
and guys here's a special deal for you
try Bluetooth free
when you use our promo code Theo at
checkout just pay five dollar shipping
that's
b-l-u-e-c-h-e-w.com promo code Theo to
receive your first month free
so take me through like some of your
process of putting music together like
when you start like where do you get
inspired these days because I know with
like jokes like I'll kind of notice
something funny that I say with my
friends and I'm like okay this is a bead
on something you know it's almost like a
welder when they light that beat up and
then they start using the B to do all
the well what is it kind of what does it
feel like for you as you've gotten to
know yourself better
honestly I listen to a lot of really old
music uh uh most most of what I mean
also know hip-hop you know when I want
to get hyped up but like most like when
I'm casually listening to like on an
airplane or whatever it is it's usually
like some you know something 40s to 70s
era
a lot of times I'll just find a sample
in there that I really like in the vibe
of it I'll send it to like I got a
couple producers that are really good
with flipping those
um and then in the end we'll we'll
replay it with our own instruments so
that like there's less legal [ __ ] to go
through
um also I mean half a sessions I do I'll
just go in with the producer we'll kind
of chop it up a little bit and think of
something like the song Soiree I dropped
not long ago uh I walked in I was like
hey bro let's make a like a Beethoven
joint let's make a Beethoven song and he
was like all right bet and he just shot
at the Willy legendary producer Just
Whipped out his [ __ ]
piano recorded it and played like this
Beethoven ass gas uh uh track and I spat
on it and it depends but
but usually like it's either in person
with a producer starting from scratch
and I'm like a big part of the
production process or I'm sending a
sample and we're gonna you know go step
by step
and as far as the one that's like about
30 seconds in it kind of changes to a
total is that the one that flips to like
a total different I think about the
intro probably the intro isn't it
marvelous is the intro to my my album
which is like this like Smooth 80s
little funky John and then it changes
into like this hard trap beat and it
keeps going back and forth so far is the
second song where it's like this organ
playing that dwelly played and uh man
that one came out hot that's something
that's interesting about you when I'm
listening it's like I can't I don't it's
like I'm in different time periods kind
of you know it's almost like I'm just
trying yeah I feel like I'm just kind of
traveling through uh joyful different
moments in in in time and in music it's
kind of cool I like to really mix it up
and like have these be different like I
I don't like having multiple songs on a
project that are the same where a lot of
artists it's like they have a style and
all the beats are going to sound in a
certain
you know range where all the beats are
going to be similar like a Playboy cardi
or like a little Uzi like their beats
are all like in the same sort of style
but I like to like really mix it up and
like
I think I think a lot of artists it's
better for them to make a specific style
that they rock with but for me it's like
my voice My My lyrics my you know sort
of just
style and you know
regalia all that yeah Simon Rex shout
out yeah shout out to Simon Rex all that
kind of speaks for itself and then beats
I just want to try new things every time
um what about BG dude he might be
somebody that'd be interesting he's kind
of been gone BG knockout no like uh the
BG do you remember him uh he was part of
like um I mean the BG's themselves are
who I kind of based my style off of oh
dang so they had a rap ride in New
Orleans called BG and I know BG knockout
who's from Compton but I don't know
about BG yeah they had can you bring him
up Zach
um neurons y'all did have some blank
blank yeah that every time you come
around my city blank blank I think it
rain word about 50 minutes I'm about it
man yeah he was with little Wayne in the
beginning they were uh bro that early
[ __ ] is so him juvenile juvenile used to
live in a neighborhood over from me when
I was growing up and so we heard this
crazy story one night that he chased
some women down the street with an ice
pick and then we all went out and bought
his album
[Music]
fire man that's Prime marketing right
there oh dude we were like oh we were
buying ice picks and [ __ ] people give
each other ice picks like his uh
stocking stuffers bro New Orleans y'all
got so what Lil Wayne juvenile got that
old troop Birdman DJ Khaled did you
capture New Orleans people don't know
that [ __ ] I thought it was from Miami
wow people pull up DJ Khaled
yes suicide boys have you ever met
suicide boys yeah and I've asked Grim to
come on the Pod that would be a good
what if you guys did something that
could be interesting we've they brought
me on tour I've been on tour with them
and we've like I'm pretty close with
them they're very they're very strict
about their uh there you go New Orleans
yeah they don't like to yeah I mean the
scrim doesn't party you know and so they
don't party and they really don't want
to collab with people but like we we've
done enough shows together and stuff
where I feel like it could happen pretty
soon yeah they're specific about their
world you know yeah they're really
specific about their world scrims like
that he's uh you know he's got he's do
he does exactly what he's doing they're
kind of like genius man I I really
respect them and and like I'm inspired
by the suicide boys they're so sick yeah
I love them I saw screaming I keep in
touch a decent amount and um and who do
I see on their Shakewell was with them
cheddah they had uh I was on I was on
that tour was on my tour yeah I was on
the one it was a cheddar Shakewell me
Ramirez uh Derm
uh turnstile this was like last year
they just did they just did another
wrong with ski mask but this time I was
like the the schemat I was like the the
direct support and it was sick wow
something on a few shows and they were
they wanted to have Chief Keef too but
he didn't show up oh damn that's uh
Chief Keef is a great dude
don't get me wrong I've kicked it with
him a lot always dude like he doesn't
talk a lot but every any time he says
anything it's really cool wow and and
he's just a very giving person and
anytime I've asked him to get on a song
he just slays it he's fire loves you
peeve
sway Lee is sick that would be fire I
haven't met him but I have a lot of
mutual friends that's a good idea nicest
dude man I got to meet him at the Super
Bowl and his uncle is a comedian this
guy Sully McCullough
I'd always like I knew that they were
out of Mississippi so I'd always be
talking to him about it and stuff like
that and like I knew that
um that he was related and then I was at
the Super Bowl and he was there and I
was just so and he was literally the
probably the nicest dude in the room
just slowly just so cool I mean he so
everything about him is just it seems
really cool you know but it was cool but
he was real real friendly so yeah I love
many people that are like really really
up and are so friendly you know yeah
it's hard to find sometimes
yeah I think it's like I think that's
about your energy it's like people want
to work with you because they want to be
around you too you know I think that's
probably a big aspect for people
um I actually ended up the last two
years getting booked uh
as the mo I was the most books College
artist the last two years really yeah
you've been playing colleges I was the
most booked artist at colleges the last
two years and that's purely because
we're professional we pull up we're
really nice to everybody and so I did
like I think like 40 shows at colleges
last year and about like 35 this year
and are you going through Naka and stuff
like that do you go to the like through
the concert like is it specifically for
the college or is it college town it's
it's College it's like their actual like
spring festival or like they're like
Fall Festival it's sick dude yeah yeah
that's a tough Market to do on a lot of
times and it just worked out man there's
a lot of my fans of these college girls
and then I meet the promoters who a lot
of them will book for tons of different
colleges and like if we get along well
it's like that that's really important
in music and I think every industry is
like if you're just a good person and
like not a dick and like like do what
they ask like
me it's me and Waka Flocka are like the
two like top that's because Waka Flocka
is a great down to earth guy
Waka Flocka and I did a few shows
together and he brought me aside and we
meditated together he's vegan oh damn
dude he is like not what you'd expect
and it's awesome great down to earth
fella about my height way stronger when
you see people that are your height do
you think that you are is there a better
chance you're going to be friends
it's a really good question I feel like
there's like a little bit of a bonding
with tall people you know some some of
them will you know instantly come in
with like the the opposite feeling like
oh like oh he's the other tall guy you
know
um like hype beef kind of [ __ ] yeah like
I think I can't remember I'm at G-Eazy
and I think it might have been that way
I don't know anyways most most tall
people yeah we have a little bit of a
bond you know we dap up and be like hey
man pleasure you know stay long stay
long bro you long drink of water yeah
Thomas has a lot of chicks that's what I
always hear it's easy yeah he went to
school in Loyola and New Orleans
actually which is kind of interesting
wow um yeah
yeah I think the BG would be pretty sick
man he's like a rapper that was really
fire and then he's had a tough time
mystical I really loved mysticals
yeah I'm talking crazy about me again
yeah
but he keep going to jail he keeps doing
pedophilia or pedophilia okay well I
probably won't collab with him then yes
I'm popping him yeah they keep popping
him down to the next on to the next uh
man Morgan Wallen and Hardy we got that
it we got that locked in and have Ernest
ride it man Ernest is a great writer
that works with them so help have him
help right all right cool yeah Ernest uh
he's uh flower shops
you ever heard it that's a song It's a
Beautiful Day what is it Morgan Wallen
all night I actually have heard it I
have her I have a roommate who will wake
up every morning he sleeps on our couch
he's like our couch dweller wakes up
every morning plus Morgan Wallen yeah
that's all I wake up most days that
could be me easily
um Zach Brian have you heard of him
is I have heard of Zach Brian dude I
went to his show it was so cool I rolled
up Cheeto Vera is there from the UFC
right so I love UFC and so it was the
craziest like he's Ecuadorian like um
like I think he's Ecuadorian isn't he
I know Zach Brian just like Brian yeah I
don't have a name you know who's gonna
come to my show the other night was
sugar Shawn oh he was sure Sean O'Malley
you met him I could see him being in a
video years easily he was so hyped man I
wish he could have made it it was it was
in Phoenix it was the night before uh
before LA and man we were just like I
don't know how we even met but you guys
remind me of each other actually the way
that you kind of keep in touch yeah
he'll just kind of send a picture
sometimes just something crazy you know
what's up
um his energy gets read wrong I think
sometimes about people because he just
has such this uh you know he's kind of
gotten into podcasting he's so much also
like an artist outside of his fighting
right so I think a lot of Fighters
initially it seemed like we're like what
the [ __ ] is this dude he's not a real
fighter you know uh because he's able to
manage two different real businesses in
a lot of ways he's sick but man he's uh
yeah he's so good his Energy's always
fun man his whole life and he like this
the way he's able to just kind of record
his life and he doesn't stress about it
too much kind of he yeah I often uh I um
admire him I admire his ability to not
like kind of like get too overwhelmed or
anything I would get too spun up you
know how do you feel about uh Jake Paul
we talked about this on that BFS podcast
I don't I mean I met Jake just through
his brother and I you know and I was I
was talking more with Logan and and
anytime I've ever been in the same space
as those guys
but I think he's he's serious about
boxing you know I used to think the dude
was so lame and he I mean way back like
like I met him and he was pretty
actually cool dude and now like I think
he's undefeated against all these like
professional fighters like
like yes marketing is douchey and he's
got his own thing going but like it's
pretty badass man like I got I gotta
show love to him Logan's a really good
dude too I like Logan Oh Logan seems
really Logan is cool I've interacted
with him a lot more Jake it's like you
know I don't know if I'll be your friend
but I think you are a badass my friend
Jake seems tougher to get to know kind
of he seems like his own
he he like you know he seems like he
kind of stays in his own world a bit
Logan's obviously just super busy dude
um but yeah he's always fun to you know
always enjoy being around those guys and
they crush it oh yeah I'm just impressed
I think that both of them were
considered like lame like like I just
did not [ __ ] with them at all just based
on like what I'd heard like I hadn't
even like looked into it and then they
did the riot moves to become kind of
sick again you know they fought they
they literally tried fighting which is
like impressive they train from nothing
yeah and killed it and uh you know like
they're doing a lot of dope [ __ ] so I
got respect for those guys now well you
have to admire their commitment uh the
ability to kind of evolve right to make
that choice to go from you know what
people would call a YouTube star or a
YouTube Fame which has got to be so like
I can't even imagine coming up on that
being horrible diss tracks all that it's
just trash but then you come in and you
find I think they just find what they're
meant to be Man the fighting space and
then he went to that Japanese mistletoe
thing or whatever and they [ __ ]
rocked him about that for some reason
he's like what are you doing you know I
remember him filming a dead person
hanging from a tree
that's what you're probably thinking of
he went to the Japanese suicide forest
yeah it wasn't mistletoe it was a dead
man oh damn
well I mean that's the damn Grim
Reaper's mistletoe son well I guess so
man hey I still [ __ ] with y'all yeah and
it's yeah I mean a lot yeah nobody wants
to be a part of suicide or anything I
can't but also in Japan they don't have
a lot of room to do stuff I think so I
think they have to do things like in
certain areas there's not a lot of room
there there's interesting like cultural
I talked to some psychiatrists about
this like this interesting like
different countries have cultural like
views on suicide and stuff and it's like
I think Japan has the highest rate of
suicide because it's like just kind of
like part of their culture and like
embred it in their in their in their
inbredded is that is that a term
embedded embedded I've seen it dude yeah
you know the inbreds I know the embed
yeah embedded in their brain I've seen
it they got some Square tits yeah man um
pull up the Japanese suicide I would
like to know a little bit more about it
just so we can yeah so I have some clear
side forwards I've heard a lot about it
anyways Japan and like Russia and is
there one other country where they have
like just culturally like they have like
the suicide like statistics are crazy
different than anywhere else wow I think
Russia in particular it's like a crazy
amount okigara yeah it's this it's this
one here it's just a heavily Woody is it
Forest
also known as the sea of trees is a
forest on the Northwestern flank of
Mount it's on that one yeah how many
people do how many people commit suicide
the people also ask it
30 every year about 30 people committing
suicide there every year so for one
place imagine if there was one Park you
know that's like that's like more than
one that's like three a month man that's
crazy
yeah imagine being like the park ranger
you know
you're the park ranger and you just got
to pull up and you're like oh there's
there's another yeah cause that's one
every other week yeah
and I wonder if it's like a busy season
guaranteed bro like when it's cold out
and [ __ ] hmm
beautiful place too wait maybe that's
why too I think that it you know it
looks like it's such a beautiful place
you and I saw this crazy Tick Tock the
other night a guy
guys
trying to hang himself and a guy walks
up on him and is recording a video and
like talks him out of it and it's all on
video and the dude's like bawling crying
and stuff like
sometimes I'm like is some of this on
Tick Tock is it even real but this thing
looked pretty much it sounds real that's
uh I think that'd be
there are people that fake some wax [ __ ]
but I think that'd be that'd be pretty
[ __ ] whack to fake that yeah can you
see that Zach do you I don't know how
you would even look like I'm trying to
find it I'm trying and I know it's
probably gonna set off alarms even
looking for it
wow
um when did you start to feel like okay
I'm turning I'm turning a corner here so
so you you know you end up at the
commune you got the music going you've
obviously had some uh juvenile issues
starting out like out of the gate
trouble in Georgia
um
you can't you you know but you have this
vibe that everybody loves you're doing
music when does it start to kind of turn
for you and you realize okay I really
have to lean into this or or you just
realize that it's getting bigger yeah it
was right at the end of my uh my commune
stay in Montana I was just finishing up
that probation I had about a year left
in college and I was working hello did I
I was going crazy I was so motivated
that I was a full-time student 18
credits at University of Wisconsin and
Madison Madison yeah gang baby yeah I
think it was Comedy on State perform
there oh I remember coming that's first
place I ever got kicked out of yeah in
my life yeah man places are great
anyways I uh I was doing that I was
working 20 hours a week at this place
that would have probably ended up being
my job if it wasn't you know for the
music stuff that popped up and uh I ran
this pizza company with my homie
basically the pizza roller basically
what we did
for about almost two years we bought
like a souped up golf cart and we put
this trailer on the back that was like
this metal thing that kept things warm
partner with a partner with a low local
pizza chain and what was it called uh
I was about to say Fazoli's no it's it
was a great pizza place fabians or
something I don't know it was it was it
wasn't the best pizza in town but it was
like we would hire kids to drive this
thing around play music put lights on it
and they would sell pizza above a slice
to the drunk kids the little bars so we
do it we do it four nights a week they
go out there from like 9 00 p.m till 3
A.M and just sell pizza at all the
drunkens yeah and that was like that was
like my first business after that took
off and we made we made a good a good
bag on that while we were students yeah
and you're giving the people what they
want it's what you've always done you're
giving the people what thank you thank
you and and then I uh man I think I had
like a year left of college and
uh receiver like oh I'd take this job in
Atlanta they're gonna make this my own
office and like run this whole program
or it's like I really like this rap
stuff and it's kind of starting to take
off but it was like yeah right at the
end of that probation period in Montana
I had a song that blew up and they
posted on Bleacher Report and I was like
Hey like this is kind of lit and then I
said you know what like I love you all
but I'm taking the summer off I need to
like do this and then I just kept
grinding and uh Finally Revealed my face
that whole time I hadn't revealed my
face my first two years I was like under
wraps because I didn't want anyone to
know about it because I thought it was
lame I was like I was afraid of people
discovering me and being like Oh that's
Matt Harry like like what's he doing and
my boss obviously I'm rapping about like
piping my dentist and [ __ ] I didn't want
my boss to see that oh yeah so so I
didn't reveal my face at all I was just
posting all these like 50s pinup girls
as my artwork and like all my
announcements and everything were like
were you self-conscious
a little bit I didn't want to be that
guy that was like at least in my town
there was maybe like seven of them that
were like the rappers that were like
handing out mixtapes I don't want to be
that guy at all so I didn't tell any of
my good friends besides like my
roommates until like a year in I was
like once I have some like actual
following I'll tell people
and uh I finally
actually met a guy at a party it was it
was at a party I met this dude
named Charlie still my boy he uh he
recognized my voice
recognize my voice and he said happened
to be a videographer he recognized my
voice when I was talking to music bro
are you are you young gravy I never even
mentioned where I was from or anything I
I faked like I was from Atlanta and then
I faced like from New York this dude
recognized my voice ended up being a
videographer we made the Miss clean
video which is like probably my biggest
music video now that's how I revealed my
face uh
I partly blew up just because everyone
thought I was black and then they were
like because my voice and everyone was
like oh he's a white dude yeah like a
skinny white dude riding a horse black
throat white else and uh yeah
and then I uh
that was that man then it really that
popped off got a million views in a week
and I was like all right something
serious is happening it's big and going
then when something goes like that
they're like damn okay now I'm now this
is what I am and I started getting flown
out to like labels in New York and I had
to like skip did it was sick I was
walking to my like college lectures and
I was a marketing major so it's 80 girls
in those classes and I walk in there
with my letter from like Universal Music
Group I'd be like yo I'm sorry brother
I'd say it's super loud to it but yo man
my bad like I gotta I gotta go meet with
the label about this record deal real
quick man I had a nice last little
semester there any babies want to roll
four babies at all she's trying to pull
up man
no yeah so that was that's how I knew
and uh
ended up getting a tour booked and I
started one week after I graduated
couldn't make the graduation ceremony
because I had a show in New York damn
you think you'll ever go back and walk
try not
I could just like get a you know I could
should I it might be a Cool vibe I mean
maybe a cool
be pretty fire maybe kind of tired I'm
going I'm going back to my high school
for the first time in like 10 years oh
yeah uh over Christmas to do a little
charity event which would be cool that's
awesome yeah yeah maybe I will do maybe
we'll go walk [ __ ] it
um
what's in the news Zach let's let's just
see what's happening in the world oh you
talked about a stalker they had another
stalker that happened what was that some
celebrity was dealing with it
yeah Kim K uh we saw this in the news
she got a restraining order against a
guy who I guess claims that he's talking
to her telepathically oh see that's I
think this is one of the byproducts you
get of like this metaverse thing and
like a lot of these uh avatars is that
people
start to believe then that they are
in instances with you
uh this man it says
um
Andre persoud
uh is prohibited from contacting her
purse out showed up at her home at least
three times oh
um
yeah you say 100 yards away for the next
five years what does he mean
telepathically is he getting we is he
doing did he probably bought one of the
they probably had a free ouija board
with one of those lip kits or something
yeah I guess he claimed to be he claimed
to be armed and showed up at her house
three times so that's pretty yeah that's
not that's not the vibe at all man yeah
and also these [ __ ] seem like ghosts
now anyway almost so it's like I'm not
surprised that if one of them showed up
through Ouija
God damn what else they got man yeah you
were talking about school they just
announced what the Oxford dictionary
2022 word of the year is oh let's get it
you ready mm-hmm
the Oxford dictionary Award of the year
what do you think it would be based on
this year so far what would you each
Cass oh that's a good question
gas
that's a good one extra extra
definitions now let me think what's a
word that hasn't been is it gonna be
like a word that's been used very often
or something yeah they're adding new
yeah what is it yeah the whole the vibe
is every year it's like what kind of
enters the Lexicon the Oxford dictionary
thinks that they need to start okay you
know trying to think about like social
media and what people really say a lot
Tick Tock yeah I mean I'll take talks I
think a tick tock like you know what I'm
saying like a tick tock top Vibe yes two
s y a s s that's a good call uh oh I
would say Vibe Vibe Vibe Vibe has been
around for a little while that's the
thing is you can't you can't use a word
that exists uh oh yeah
um
oh man
what about that uh but does see people
say badussy [ __ ] I don't think they put
busty in there but busy does me a boy
[ __ ] yeah or ass [ __ ] they used to
call it ass [ __ ] ass [ __ ] yeah respect
um I remember this lady at this gas
thing she wouldn't always say y'all
trying to get that ass [ __ ] every time
we'd stop there to get some gas and we
didn't know what she was talking about
dude huh she was a dude she might have
been well now she's offering that ass
[ __ ] uh we can't get it man what's up
what is it are you ready for it Goblin
mode Goblin mode oh my God that is
[ __ ] funny man
I don't know exactly what it means but
it's just I think I do know what it
means describes as unapologetically
self-indulgent lazy slovenly or greedy
Behavior oh that's America I regularly
enter Goblin mode man that is funny I
was expecting worse
that's the definition Goblin mode so who
yeah whose fans are goblin Motors then I
wonder
uh Playboy cardi for sure yeah his fans
are Tweakers are they oh yeah damn
they're cool but they're just like I'll
say yeet fans though yeah and what about
as little do they still have is that a
done thing you think people being named
little something like little because it
kind of turned into like Oh I'm a young
right keep that in mind before you speak
uh am I young but I spell it a special
way
I mean little baby is one of the most
simple names that I've ever heard and he
is one of the biggest artists on Earth
good point uh
yeah they had a little peep they had
because then it started ASAP is out now
ASAP is coming up yep yeah yep but
that's a part of a click you know it's
like it's like me and the other Youngs
aren't really a clique you know oh so
ASAP is part of a click ASAP everything
is a click yeah oh I didn't know that
group yeah yeah oh wow I think it's
always driving prosper
pretty dope I think everyone in ASAP is
cool it is I didn't realize that I just
thought ever it was just random
you got young you got a little
you got a couple bigs out there big boy
Big Sean
um
I wonder would be a good name can we see
what the other words are for the past
couple years
yeah I'm curious a good name you think
about a rapper name for you
um
we go man we go
uh
hmm what to let people comment hey if
you're watching on YouTube put below
what you think my rapper name would be
and it can be good or bad you can make
fun of me if you want
thick
oh yeah
oh something GED would be good A little
GED yeah
um no that doesn't really work
uh thalamus
victorium
GED oh damn that sounds pretty good I
found this Victorian GED that sounds
like uh like some Harry Potter pervy
Harry Potter kind of some horny [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh I've been
horned out
these are the other words of the Year
ASAP horny ASAP horny that's not bad
little medium
low medium is hard especially if you're
like a seancer if you read in brains for
a little medium well like throbbing
Vaughn would that would that work that
sound more like just for sex
too my mom yeah all right I want to have
a talent throat Vaughn oh I know I don't
want that dog you rap with it man come
on man throw up on I might have a lot of
dudes rolling up with that meat male
trying to put it [ __ ] trying to put a
letter in there yeah we got young gravy
and throat Vaughn man new mixtape
that's fine make them say oh
uh what do we got what are they doing
what do we got
last couple were kind of whack but so
2021 was vax like vaccination all right
whatever 2020 2020 was words of an
unprecedented year which again is like I
don't know climate emergency dude I like
how it was all this [ __ ] and then we got
Goblin mode this year dude somebody they
must have a different spot so obviously
this year is sponsored by uh by Monster
Energy dude if they went in a goblin
mode toxic
I like that man I don't know any of
these words use Quick is kind of lit
though uh it sounds a little sauce on it
post wow they add an emoji
word of the year in 2015 was an emoji
damn life sucks man oh there we go Vape
was already one selfie
squeeze the middle what's that squeezed
middle yeah that's good carbon footprint
Sudoku podcast okay 2005. there we go
2005. look at how much better things
were Brian we had Sudoku and podcast we
had carbon neutral
yeah I think it got bad in 2009 when
they called us simple as an unfriend and
now we're looking at Vape selfie and I
was getting bad yeah
yeah that's when he got weird what else
we got Zach anything else in the news
with the Hindi word of the year oh yeah
it's right there is right there go back
I couldn't I couldn't really read what
it was man maybe I don't want to
pronounce it
you got it you got it man Sam vidhan
or the Constitution I'm gonna go with uh
Autumn automata or self-reliance all
right yeah
yeah I don't have a lot of Hindi
information what I was expecting
honestly unfortunately
um what is your age range I know you do
a lot of the mill thing what is the age
range on that
um and what is the age range on that on
that Mill thing
so I'm not
um are you an age demon or is it just
matter is it just about that I think
it's going to be like I mean I think
most people probably can assume but like
you know some people just don't really
get it like
I'm not loyal to only older women no
that's not yeah people people do make
that assumption is there a video
that dropped of me walking in Buffalo
New York with this girl who was just
clearly not a MILF whole lands and it
got like six million views and all the
comments were just oh my God bro that's
not a MILF what is going on I was like
dude like
I mean yeah MILFs are dope but I'm not
I'm not it's like a solar eclipse or
something I'm not discriminating man uh
the age range I mean
dated a girl that was four years younger
than me for a little bit okay she's
sweetheart she's really she had a child
very mature she did not have a child
okay uh the oldest woman I've been with
was
um
54. okay
and that was
28 years older than me
right yeah I think that's very fair man
my
my mom and dad were 38 years apart
really yeah damn mine are 21 years apart
wow that's far it were and uh that's
although I thought was that was a lot
one of your parents passed away yeah my
dad died when I was 16. oh man so did
mine when you're 16. yeah really yeah he
had cancer [ __ ] man my dad fell in the
ice it hit his head while walking my dog
my dad was way older though my dad was
born in 1933
in Switzerland was he really yeah dude
my dad was born in 19
or 1912. damn in Nicaragua wow
damn we got a similar situation yeah so
my my grandparents Rudolph and varino
are from like 1880 or something yeah my
dad was born in 1933. mom born in like
56 and yeah 23 year difference and I uh
and here I am man I like to have an
older parents I liked it yeah well I
think it probably adds some sort of a
worldliness to you and as well like
things you know you don't even recognize
that
um
and you have to also I think I realized
I was thinking about this the other day
you're watching an older person so then
how you interact with the world and how
you interact with things is probably
going to be a little bit different than
if you have like a a capable and you
know constantly on the go father whereas
if you have someone that's probably just
um even just spending more time at peace
or relaxing or just sitting there my dad
would just sleep all the time and his
eyes would start leaking and I didn't
know what was going on he was just old
you know people get older yeah
absolutely wait so how how old was he
when he passed
he was 86. 86 while he was 16. but
that's so wild man gosh what a dark
surprise your dad just went for a walk
his head we were uh it was in the middle
of winter uh he slipped on my eyes hit
his head and like
didn't realize it till like five hours
later be like internal brain bleeding
and you started having a bad reaction
it's [ __ ] up because I was at my
homie's house we were like smoking and
just chilling and I got a call from my
mom like yo dad's in the hospital like
and you were stoned you should come I
was stoned and then freak me out extra I
mean about the time I got there
obviously I sobered up but I was uh yeah
it was just really bad timing
um but I think overall it kind of helped
me
in life man like I I at least looking
back I'm proud of how I how I took it
you know I I it motivated me my mom kind
of shut down for a while and couldn't do
a lot because she was just like you hit
her so hard ah um so I kind of became
the man of the house when I was 16 and I
had to get myself into college and do
all this stuff
and I think it motivated me a lot man
like I miss my dad like like [ __ ] but
but I think that that was uh you know a
turning point for me
did you get to say anything to him when
you got to the hospital or he was
unconscious no it was it was bad timing
I think right when I got there he had
just like reached the point of like not
being able to talk anymore uh seems like
kind of like coffee and [ __ ] but yeah
yeah and obviously I said [ __ ] to him I
don't know maybe hopefully you heard it
um
but yeah man that was I was 16. it was
January
uh
uh he's born in Switzerland I think I
said that and Citizen and everything man
I still see his family sometimes he had
no so he had
uh five siblings grew up in a family of
six and every single one of them has
died in an accident except for the two
that are alive who are like 95 and 96.
it's like my family's just on some [ __ ]
yeah and you just hurt yourself yeah I
do I break my my [ __ ] all the time man
it's that extra two inches two inches
man I'm I'm a survive man I'm not gonna
die I think if I die if I make it to 50
I'll be happy
um
yeah I'm sorry about that man that's
it's interesting that when that kind of
stuff happens and then how it processes
it into the rest of your life did your
mother remarry
um
my mom's had a few boyfriends since uh
and I'm always talking with her about it
we're really close my mom and I became
like best friends
not every night she's been a few on this
tour she's coming tomorrow actually
we're going to Austin Texas tomorrow uh
my mom and I are super tight man I I uh
yeah sweet as much as I can
um she's had a few boyfriends since then
but like you know I'm protective yeah
they're whack one of them was cool but
one of them was whack so you know I
think she's you know she's in love with
him so so uh she's trying things out but
uh
yeah I wonder if I fight I wonder if
love love kind of feels like it goes on
after we die doesn't it it feels like it
has like a power that's bigger than us
do you ever think about something like
that I remember at one point
uh the one time that I really felt like
I was in love with somebody was this
girl uh
I was like about three years ago and I
was like like I was more afraid of her
dying than anything else I was like she
could break up with me it's all good but
if she died like you know I was like
dude I'm gonna be [ __ ] up forever wow
you know because I was like man like I
love this [ __ ] and I don't want
you know that like forever for the rest
of my life think that like
like compare everything in my life to
her you know now that we broke up and
like everything's over and like I see
what she's on now it's like I feel
better because I'm like oh like she's
happy I'm happy we're different it makes
sense that we're separated rather than
like oh this could have been perfect and
then she died you know yeah love Yeah
well yeah uh yeah uh I mean love almost
feels dangerous and it's almost like
damn do I even want to go to this thing
that's [ __ ] scary bro you know when
it incites feelings like that and like
you know it's funny because being in
love people think like oh I want to be
in love that it just is like only this
positive thing but it's kind of got this
trap door that's you know you got to be
careful with your footing in there yeah
I think I've only been like maybe like
one or two other times one of them was
pretty recently that I kind of felt that
same way and uh man it's it's hard
because it's like yo especially with
like at least how I live and I assume
kind of how you live it's like when
you're traveling all the time it's
really hard to like you know you gotta
find the right person that's down to
like you know accept that you're gonna
be gone all the time and be all over uh
yeah be around people and you gotta see
it yeah yeah yeah so
um
yeah that's how hard look man it's hard
when there's opportunities to meet women
and did you get a lot of girls growing
up I mean you probably you seem like a
tall kind of handsomer guy you guys
usually do pretty well I'm tall
um I uh actually you know what
I think part of the reason I sort of
have game now is because when I was
um around maybe 15 16. I was part of
like this in my hometown there was the
scatters and there was the Hicks right
oh yeah and the Somalians those were
like the three small hands Somalians oh
Somalians a lot of them in Minnesota I
was like damn small hands I want a small
one a small those are my boys so it was
like those were like the three groups of
like the dudes within my hometown it's
three there's four high schools but like
still it was kind of like split uh
skater Stoners Hicks that like drove
trucks or steel toe boost numbers
volumes which were like well I mean not
just somalis the Vietnamese was
everybody but everyone kind of had their
little like Cruise uh then there's all
the girls were kind of like free game
like like all over you know what I'm
saying uh where was I even going with
this you were the question I was growing
up there was three types of people and I
was like oh do you know anything about
um
yeah it was like did you have game in
high school oh did I have a game yeah
yeah okay yeah sorry the whole thing is
uh
uh all my friends in my little skate
skater crew were handsome [ __ ]
and they're really good at skateboarding
and I wasn't that good at skateboarding
and I was had a kind of ugly skinny had
acne and [ __ ] so how to develop game in
order to wheel on the same women that
all my peers were Wheeling it on you
know what I'm saying so I developed game
early and uh
dude I used to just like go out
solo and like go to like did I was like
15 or 16 and I'll just go out to like
either like a bar and like find my way
in or like go wherever and just like
meet women sober and just like meet and
like see like try to train myself you
know and then I finally got that game
and like I had some really hot
girlfriends and in high school that made
me look ugly as [ __ ] because I was Dusty
and I never really like came up and like
kind of I kind of grew into my body when
I was in college and like you know got
the facial hair and like became like a
normal looking dude I wasn't like I
wasn't like a [ __ ] little trash can
man but I was definitely a little Dusty
okay so you kind of look like almost
like George Washington's fine son I'll
take that man [ __ ] let's go okay thank
you sir
so uh so yeah man I developed game
really on and I think that that sort of
confidence and Charisma carried into my
music and helped a lot with like just
even like any risks I was taking
yeah you got to be kind yeah you have to
be really confident up there to do that
it's interesting watching somebody it's
funny watching somebody else do their
art you can't even believe that you do
anything that's even remotely similar to
it yeah it's a bit different yeah like I
was up there with Trevor the other night
watching we're like dude we should have
freaking done music dude we're so pissed
at ourselves because it just there's
such a different energy like what comedy
is just like hey you're almost just like
hey don't you wish I could do music you
know it's almost like you just wish you
could you know
um but it's funny watching somebody else
perform sometimes it doesn't even feel
like you do anything similar to that
yeah I remember the I think I've been on
your shows but I've been a few trevors
and uh
I mean I I get so impressed with last
one I was at Chris Delia came out oh
yeah Stephanie Jessica came out and uh
Marquez and man just the
the uh what's the word just the Improv
levels we're insane man I was like very
impressed I feel like anyone who does
comedy am I wrong in thinking that
anyone who does comedy would be really
good at acting
I don't feel like you could slay that
[ __ ] yeah I think acting is just a lot
more like even I did a part in a movie
recently with Bobby Lee was a friend of
mine's movie this guy Lodge it's about a
sober living and we did some parts in it
and even watching back watching some of
the back I'm like oh acting you don't
move at all like even like I didn't
think I was moving much like when I when
we were recording but I was like oh damn
there's some parts where I'm even moving
too much like you like acting is like
you're not doing anything bro I'm you're
getting the message across but that's
all you're doing you know
um I'll probably try some acting with
Comedy Central recently that [ __ ] was
actually a lot of fun I saw what was it
uh I did like four little sketches with
them there was one I saw that was I
think it was for p it was with Pizza Hut
maybe or something I did some Pizza Hut
too yeah it was good I did with Comedy
Central I did one it was like it was
like a polyamorous rom-con and then
there was one about maybe in a human
taxidermist
uh one about me meeting God and we're
about to drop this one called uh yeah
that shit's funny oh I nutted on DMT
that one yeah that's another good one
though uh oh we I just got the Final Cut
of this one called uh clot ones I think
I can reveal like the plot it's like hot
ones but they hooked me up to a
menstrual cramp simulator and like
throwing blood at me it was it was lit
it's going dark over there yeah no it
was the whole thing was funny man Comedy
Central is dope
uh yeah I had fun I had fun doing a
little bit of acting man trying yeah
Wonder more of that yeah but yeah that's
I mean I I'm not it's like you're you're
kind of like this you're just kind of
this energy this force and I think
people want to be around it
um anything else in the news act I'm
trying to think of
uh we need a lot of news I got a kind of
a crazy video These Guys slapping each
other at an IHOP can I go pee again yeah
sure
so what uh oh take me take me through so
like you do like sampling a lot of your
music you find things you like from the
past what's that what is that like uh
what are like can you just do that take
me through some of that it's complicated
uh
uh legally you gotta like clear
everything since my lyrics are very not
friendly especially for like these older
songs where it's the estate or it's
someone older who's listening to it a
lot of times they don't like hip-hop so
trying to sort of clear something
doesn't work often
a lot of times we'll just bring ideas
into the studio and then kind of just
recreate or make something similar and
that works easier it's like it's
annoying so
I finally found producers that can just
make their own [ __ ] off the top which is
dope but yeah it's it's annoying what is
it so say if you do use a song do you
have to if you do want to use something
do you have to reach out to them first
how does that kind of work I didn't at
first when I was starting on Soundcloud
and doing all that a lot of my songs
that blew up really big I I didn't
because I didn't even know how I didn't
have I didn't have any you know legal
folks to help me with it and I uh I just
said you know what they can only sue me
for as much as I made off the song so
it's worth it because you know I also
get whatever attention I need off of it
or whatever
uh the only actual time that I've had to
like take a song fully down and like
give all the money away was George
Michael's estate with uh sampled kills
whisper and I'm signing the check this
week for the 190k but besides that it's
like
wow cool so they asked for 190 or was it
negotiated how did you have like
announcement that was just all the like
they had to like get reports not so much
money I made on the song that's a good
that's kind of a deep cut too so I was I
was impressed that they like figured all
that out but I gotta pay him that
um everybody else like we'll just you
know they'll take a little check and
they'll take like some some publishing
on the song it's like a percentage but
they usually pretty cool about it uh and
nowadays now that I'm signed and
everything I can't like I have to go
through the full process
yeah is it almost kind of a bummer it's
like once you get the popular once you
kind of get to some levels of
achievement you then have to do
it messes up my style
a lot of like sort of the Staples of my
style I can't do anymore then I have to
like try to recreate in other ways yeah
which I found ways to do which is like
you know little like old school samples
and stuff I can make my own I can make
my own sample like full-on
uh samples from scratch like a full song
but like it's not you know it's not
quite the same but but I figured out
ways to make it work so is that like say
so there's somebody who's wanting to
sample stuff they like sample and
they're trying to figure it out for
themselves if they're afraid to put
their music out there they're like a new
artist right do it would you just tell
them to do it yeah do it yeah if you're
early do it it's worth it man I I don't
have to deal with any of it until like I
mean I think
once my songs were getting more than
like 30 million streams like that was
when people started noticing it's like
before that they're not gonna if it's
some old at least they're not gonna
notice and
if you do it right like and they like
the song They're most likely going to
clear it out of like 10 different
situations I had only one of them ended
up really bad so I'd say do it I'd say
do it if you want to sample something do
it
it's worth uh worth a try
um you got arrested you said a couple
times what was one of the
take me through one of those issues yes
I know I've told a lot of these stories
but I guess I haven't really delved
fully into the the the third which was
um
I want to say December 20
19 maybe it wasn't that long ago I was
it was right before Christmas and I was
drunk in Atlanta
and uh
uh I wanted to go get some food right
yeah my whole crew without wearing
Buckhead my whole crew that was with me
they didn't want to go get any food so
then I met this random fella uh spiky
air kind of reddish uh he was like man
like what's good grab you let's let's go
get some pizza and I was like oh yeah so
we walked like two blocks and then
there's DeKalb Tire right tire store
right there on the Block
middle Buckhead oh yeah he was like yo
man this is my dad's my dad shot he's
like it's my dad's place you won't go
inside I was like of course yeah let's
get it so we got we go around back and
he tastes like a sort of like a shovel
and like props open the garage door in
the back you know I guess I just figured
it was normal I was like this is
how you get into your dad's business man
it's all good yeah and we get in there
are [ __ ] around like we're in this
tire store like some of the lights
around we're just jumping around we're
like Rolling Tires back just some drunk
dumb [ __ ] Rolling Tires back and forth
climbing on pallets like having a good
time and then right it sounds [ __ ]
erotic dude it was it was just like some
home some bonding shoe with the homie
man I don't even remember I don't
remember I know what you're saying yeah
I remember his [ __ ] name anyways yeah
I am just like look down on my phone
because someone called me and like look
back up and I just like look around and
like
body is gone he's completely gone and I
couldn't remember what his name was so
I'm in this tire store everybody's like
all the [ __ ] laying around I'm like [ __ ]
man like what do I do so I just I just
walk out the back door and there's three
cops there like guns out like flashlight
on me like get in the [ __ ] ground
could he set you up you think oh no I
didn't set me up I think what do you I
think
his dad didn't know it it was it was
some random kid who somehow knew that
like he could get in the back of his
tire shop he brought me in there and we
were like just [ __ ] around and then
he must have noticed that there was like
a cop car or something he ran and then I
just walked out like innocently and
there's three cops waiting and I got
[ __ ] arrested for breaking and
entering into a tire store oh dang bro
you know what I ended up doing bro my
Midwestern self man after all that I
went to jail for the night it was dude I
I was in this set with all these dudes
and they were just oh man it was I had
to Freestyle to like get to gain some
you know toilet access I'm sure yeah I
was at a huge sale I had to gain some
credit by freestyling wow was that scary
when you first went in a little bit but
I was like I mean I was like just stand
out I was just kind of geeking out I was
like man I can't believe this is what
led me here uh but it was Fulton County
so it was like like you know mid
mid-atlanta
uh only white dude there for sure did
anybody recognize you in the jail cell
there was one kid yeah yeah but I was
like I was just like nah let's not there
was another time where I where I my
first time going to jail was in Iowa you
know I beat up this kid who was being
racist to my friend and I actually I got
bailed out by fans because I put up a
story of me like in the jail cells that
forgot to take my phone not the cell in
like the processing area and I filmed
the other kid that I beat up and it was
him bleeding he was like oh [ __ ] you but
somehow these these fans could tell that
I was in Ames Iowa and they pulled up
and paid my bail and got me out dude
that's amazing bro got some so literally
like the the guard walks in he's like is
there a little gravy in here and I was
like yes
yes there is yes there is man so that
was a good one the tire one uh I you
know I had no explanation I was like
Yeah man so so my homie his dad owns the
place like it's all good like what's his
name I was like
I
was like [ __ ] I don't know man I was
drunk and uh
yeah so I have multiple charges of
criminal trespassing in Georgia now
and one well in in Iowa that that one
turned into an assault charge and then
basically I got a good lawyer the other
kid that was in the fight did not wow
and uh I showed up to court
he didn't he now has assault in Iowa
after getting his ass beat and I have uh
creating a raucous noise so I created a
Rocket's noise in Iowa one time
defeating racism that's what the Ruckus
noise yeah I defeated racism man it is a
raucous noise man
wow yeah that tire shop man we've all
been in some kind of instance like that
we're just yeah wrong place man and I
think it was Christmas Christmas Eve
that my friend built me out the next
morning it's Christmas Eve god it feels
good getting out of jail doesn't it
something nice about it so good dude
when when they come in yourself because
because they don't pay attention in jail
if you're if you're in there if you have
any questions anything you even want to
like you know even want food you little
turn down the AC on you get your ass all
cold and [ __ ] anything you want they'll
just not even look at you if you ask for
it but like when that dude comes in and
finally says like yo
Matthew Harry
it's your time to go
I think I showed a tear just about every
time we had last dude that's almost
so what about when you go out wardrobe
did y'all go eat or something you just
go rest what do you do when you get out
I never got now ah get out of jail you
never you've never gone you've gotten
out of jail one time and this dude in
there kept yelling I remember I got in
there we were smoking weed and um some
people's house and the cops show up and
then they bring two children down from
upstairs
and I'm like whose children is it and
they're like that's a great question
y'all are y'all are getting contributing
to the delinquencies of minors
hurry uh I'll probably
19. so they brought these two children
down and they almost look like Bots for
like plants dude like I'm sure they
brought their pictures up the back steps
you know like yeah it would just anyway
they're like rubbing their eyes it
looked too fake right when I'm had a
little doll on their hand I'm like these
you know what I'm saying and we were
just sitting in a living room smoking
weed so we all went in a jail I got
locked up with this one kid this one
dude who kept taking his shirt off and
screaming that he wasn't a homosexual
you know
and I didn't accuse him of being a
homeless you know I think he thought I
think he you know like he thought if you
went to jail that you were going to be a
homosexual you know and it's like I you
know I was like I'm not being homosexual
so you're good dude chill bro like and
he kept taking his [ __ ] shirt off I
think he was trying to trap me like I
could do it like a gay trap but
um that reminds me the first the first
time I got locked up it was in um also
in Georgia it was eight of us uh but but
I was we were at a house party wrong
place for a long time blah blah blah
every time wrong place one time that's
got to be here next time in the end I
got a uh charged a bunch of [ __ ] and uh
that's what led to the Montana thing but
this situation when we got there they
they kept calling me a Yankee and they
were like not [ __ ] with me because
everyone else was from Georgia I'm the
Minnesota kid this is like backwards
like Deliverance Georgia oh yeah and
they're calling me a Yankee and [ __ ] and
they put all eight all seven my friends
in one cell together and they put me in
a separate one with this dude Danny
Danny was a uh a pedophile on an oxygen
machine so it was like it was like I'm
kind of like they're kind of [ __ ] on me
but they're kind of Knob but they
clearly hated this [ __ ] so they were
putting they put the the the thermostat
down to like 55 and I'm in there and I'm
I was hiding the wood so I'm in like a
t-shirt and some shorts and I'm wet and
Danny luckily got two blankets because
he's you know got something wrong with
him so he gave me a blanket he told me a
lot bro I was in there for probably 24
hours I learned a lot of [ __ ] from Danny
man Reading Pennsylvania he told me
everything about that damn City
try to teach me how to hotwire car uh
with no car in front of you this free
license yeah just like imagining it and
uh about how he didn't actually rape
anyone and you know it was it was
interesting like you know 24 hours but
uh
but yeah man I they just
when they get you in that situation and
you're like in the [ __ ] pen it's like
they have all the power and it's like
you know what I don't like this kid he's
not from where I'm from so I'm gonna put
him in here with a pedophile and what
about nighttime do they have night time
in there where they sure it's like
lights off kind of thing no there's no
lights off no this is like jail like
holding it's like in between jail and
prison so it's like they really want to
[ __ ] with you and make you feel like
[ __ ] so like there's no lights off
temperatures low I was sleeping on like
a little Civil War book that Danny got
as a gift from somebody yeah no I I
didn't get processed for like 14 hours
so I was there I was on the floor no bed
or anything and you can have your phone
with you no hell no no it was Iowa
Georgia the the jail system was [ __ ]
up Iowa
they just lacked and they just forgot to
take my phone so I had it but now in
Georgia it was like everything was taken
on site yeah man
they don't like they don't like me down
there Georgia just does not [ __ ] with me
I'm banned from a few strip clubs in
Georgia and [ __ ]
I could see that though I used to fight
people a lot that was my problem I used
to fight people really so I fought some
bouncers at Claremont Lounge you ever
been there yeah I'm banned from there
forever if they have like a wanted
poster up for me type [ __ ] yeah that's
so great I have a really good friend
who's a professional MMA fighter that I
always go out with there so it's like
I used to get into this like mentality
like oh I don't give a [ __ ] I'll do
whatever I want because if we're in a
fight I'm with Joe Bradley and uh yeah
man and then I got bad from Clermont
Lounge God yeah Claremont dude I bought
drugs in there and people you don't know
if they're me everybody's you know it's
sort of like a um
it's like a little like a wild card and
Uno everything yeah it's everything it's
draw fours draw 400 bro everybody in
there yeah
dude everything's wild in there it is
right it's wild it's a great place if
you've never been to Claremont Lounge um
there's senior citizen strippers in
there and a lot of people have heard
about it by now but it is a great place
to go in a lot of closeted men will go
in there and like who have families and
stuff and they'll meet other men in
there I noticed but yeah there's just
breasts that are beyond what you can oh
you really pictures anything's a tit in
that bed yeah you can picture like you
picture the biggest breasts you've ever
seen and they have bigger there new we
used to do this fun thing in our class
and school one of us would go behind
they had a chalkboard and a little bit
of space between the chalkboard and the
wall and one of us would go back in
there and put you'd like kind of get
your pants down the river and pull your
nuts like over your wiener kind of and
pretend like it was a baby's head it
looked like a baby's head and you were
having a baby and then you'd uh what
what kind of brought this to to mind
right now just something kids you know
okay like um
I don't know what were you talking about
a second I was talking about big tits at
Claremont Lounge yes I'll just thinking
about crazy [ __ ] okay all right fair
enough yeah but it's like it would
almost look like a baby kinda but I
remember the goat they used to call the
goat oh yeah pushing it back you push it
back and you bend over yeah yeah this
one you kind of pull your nuts oh you
kind of like create this it looks like a
baby's head coming out of your body it's
actually it's cool it's pretty dope it's
pretty artistic it's cool that's kind of
like a Halloween it's kind of like a
Halloween kind of vibe you know
definitely soda it looks like a
meteorous landing yeah so we gotta wait
another couple Seasons before we get
that again man yeah yeah just missed
Halloween man yeah you don't get that
every month bro
um gravy uh the tourists keep going on
how long is this tour going to go on uh
December 16th we got let me think we're
doing I'm flying to Austin Texas
tomorrow my mom's birthday tomorrow
she's pulling up with my half sister
we're gonna have a good time and then we
got four shows in a row in Texas then I
come back here actually I just booked my
flights today I have three off days I'm
coming back here to help for a little
bit and let me do the West Coast like uh
Seattle Vancouver Boise couple couple
little spots and then uh I'm a free man
man there you go yeah and you pick back
up February 9th next year yeah I got
some random uh Australia I'm doing the
I'm doing the avns in January and I got
like one show I think in like
Florida and then yeah Australia man amen
man Australia New Zealand Tasmania and
Hawaii I never thought I'd ever go to
Tasmania but I'm going there with the
venga boys remember boom boom boom boom
I want you in my room the night together
boom on the same stage oh dang that's
great that's great
oh man well
um thanks so much bro for coming in and
spending time thanks for uh inviting me
out to your show the other night yeah
baby glad you made it glad you liked it
too yeah it's just yeah yeah just like
it made me want to go to more shows it
made me want to have more fun a little
bit that's what it kind of did for me
it's like oh this is fun man everybody
here is having a good time that's cool
that's the goal man I'm glad people like
we're trying to make the show like epic
but fun and like you know everyone
comfortable I could not help but have a
good time and and also you see that
earned out MILF it's like you got it
that's crazy the urn MILF is insane man
respect to him and her man gang maybe uh
young gravy thanks man thank you brother
gang baby I'll see you later always I'll
see you soon man thank you
[Music]
[Music]